y
[Música]
el grupo talibán prometió respetar a las
mujeres pero dentro de la ley islámica y
las convoco a ser parte del gobierno
además declaró una amnistía para los
empleados estatales la comunidad
internacional y también las mujeres
afganas en el exilio mostraron
desconfianza sobre estas concesiones
mientras tanto los gobiernos de
diferentes países avanzan contrarreloj
para evacuar a sus ciudadanos personal
diplomático y también aliados francia y
alemania- enviaron aviones militares a
través de los emiratos árabes y uzbekos
tan mientras que eeuu intenta acelerar
la evacuación de unas 10.000 personas un
operativo que puede durar unas dos
semanas más
y en haití el terremoto de magnitud 7.2
deja hasta el momento más de 1900
muertos y unos 9.000 900 personas
heridas los sobrevivientes ahora bajo
carpas y campamentos improvisados hacen
frente al paso de la tormenta tropical
grave que también afectó a ese país
caribeño
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora vamos a comenzar en
afganistán en donde el talibán le pidió
a las mujeres unirse a su gobierno la
comunidad internacional y también miles
de mujeres afganas alrededor del mundo
han expresado su preocupación ante la
llegada al poder del grupo talibán y
dicen no creer en sus concesiones las
mujeres y los menores de edad fueron el
grupo poblacional que más afecto a las
políticas radicales del talibán en su
gobierno de 1996 al 2001 el informes de
marina sardina
leyendo pasajes del corán luego de
visitar a las mujeres afganas a unirse a
su gobierno el grupo talibán señaló
durante su primera conferencia de prensa
que respetan los derechos de las mujeres
musulmanas pero bajo los principios de
la rigorista ley sharia
[Música]
las mujeres tendrán todos sus derechos
ya sea en el trabajo o en otras
actividades porque las mujeres son clave
para nuestra sociedad y estamos
garantizando todos sus derechos dentro
de los límites del islam
este martes un pequeño grupo de mujeres
manifestó en público su rechazo a los
talibán incluso un portavoz del grupo
insurgente fue entrevistado por una
periodista afgana en directo pero para
aquellas mujeres que vivieron bajo el
yugo de los fundamentalistas estas
promesas son sólo una cortina de humo
los talibanes dan mensajes
tranquilizadores sobre la concesión de
los derechos básicos de las mujeres
sobre la garantía de los derechos de las
mujeres pero su acción sobre el terreno
o sus prácticas son diferentes así que
ellas las mujeres tienen miedo tienen
miedo de volver o de ser encarceladas en
sus casas como lo hacían durante el
régimen talibán de 2001
wang generar la tercera ciudad más
grande de afganistán estas alumnas han
retomado esperanzadas las clases sin
dejar de lado el hiyab islámico que los
talibanes se exigen a las mujeres
estamos contentas de que nuestras
escuelas hayan comenzado y podamos
continuar nuestros estudios y esperamos
que los talibanes no obstaculicen
nuestro progreso para que podamos ayudar
a nuestra nación a desarrollarse como
otros países área corazón las
organizaciones de derechos humanos y
activistas feministas de la región
muestran su preocupación puesto que
durante el gobierno talibán entre 1996 y
2001 las mujeres y niñas fueron
despojadas de todos sus derechos
la posición de los talibanes es más o
menos la misma pero hemos visto pequeñas
diferencias especialmente en términos de
educación de las niñas
algunos analistas creen que este ligero
cambio de actitud es una máscara de cara
a la comunidad internacional en eeuu el
gobierno del presidente joe biden mostró
su preocupación dado que muchas de las
armas y también del equipo militar con
los que por dos décadas libraron una
guerra cara a cara contra el talibán
ahora ha caído en manos de los
insurgentes
creemos que esto puede durar hasta el 31
de agosto estamos hablando con ellos
sobre cuál es el cronograma exacto y
cómo se desarrollará no quiero hablar en
público sobre cuál es la mejor forma de
resolver el problema y la mejor manera
de sacar a la mayor cantidad de personas
los talibanes nos han informado que
están preparados para proporcionar el
paso seguro de civiles al aeropuerto y
tenemos la intención de mantenernos en
ese compromiso y los gobiernos de
diferentes países del mundo intentan
avanzar en el proceso de evacuación de
sus connacionales también aliados y
funcionarios diplomáticos destacados en
afganistán alemania evacuó en un avión
militar un grupo de personas hasta la
ciudad de tashkent la capital de
uzbekistán por su parte el ejército
estadounidense coordina con el talibán
para acelerar la evacuación de sus
aliados y ciudadanos un operativo que
les puede tomar por lo menos dos semanas
de otra parte ya están en territorio
francés las primeras 41 personas
evacuadas por francia en un vuelo
militar a través de los emiratos árabes
unidos- el presidente manuel marco
prometió que también traería a todos
aquellos que colaboraron con las fuerzas
armadas francesas para garantizarles así
seguridad en territorio francés pese a
que muchos han denunciado que no ha sido
nada fácil obtener una visa para
ingresar al territorio francés
no los abandonaremos prometió emanuel
macro el presidente francés anunció que
tal como a los franceses los afganos que
colaboraron con francia también serán
evacuados
es nuestro deber y nuestra dignidad de
proteger los que nos ayudaron
intérpretes choferes cocineros y otros
conductos un número de afganos
defensores de derechos humanos artistas
periodistas y activistas están
amenazados hoy por lo que hicieron
nosotros los ayudaremos desde donde de
acuerdo con el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores francia recibió a más de 600
colaboradores afganos y a sus familias
desde que los combates se intensificaron
en mayo elevando la cifra a más de 1300
personas desde que las fuerzas francesas
se retiraron en 2013 sin embargo sacar
una visa francesa no ha sido fácil para
todos a principios de este año france24
conoció a nacer un intérprete para la
armada francesa a quien le negaron la
visa francesa cinco veces él huyó del
país por temor a represalias del grupo
talibán
me curo la cara para que no me
reconozcan
cambio de casa cada dos tres o seis
meses
por el momento solo quienes estén en
peligro por haber colaborado con el
occidente fueron elegibles para una visa
francesa antoine hoy y un abogado que
representa a afganos que trabajaron para
francia dice que el anuncio de macrón
podría facilitar las cosas para otros
por primera vez el presidente dijo que
teníamos que proteger a los que ayudaron
a las tropas francesas
eso es algo que nunca habíamos escuchado
por primera vez francia dejó claro que
iba a protegerlos
parís envió refuerzos hacia el
aeropuerto de kabul para acelerar el
proceso de evacuación incluyendo la
emisión de visas para los afganos que
buscan la seguridad con desespero
vamos a cambiar de tema hablamos ahora
de haití de acuerdo con el conteo
oficial en ese país las víctimas
mortales superan ya los 1900 mientras
que la de los heridos superan los 9 mil
900 que junto con los pacientes de kobe
19 han llevado al colapso del sistema de
salud de haití los sobrevivientes del
terremoto de 7.2 que sacudió a esta
nación caribeña permanecen en carpas y
en campamentos improvisados bajo las
intensas lluvias y también inundaciones
que deja la tormenta tropical grave
previamente conversamos con alessandra
giúdice andrea coordinadora general de
médicos sin fronteras en haití y nos
comentó sobre el trabajo que están
avanzando en la ciudad de lekai que es
la ciudad más afectada por este reciente
terremoto esto fue lo que nos contó
nosotros en los departamentos del sur ya
estábamos presentes porque normalmente
tenemos proyectos de asistencia de salud
el equipo estaba presente pero para otra
actividad toda la infraestructura del
proyecto se dañó así que la primera
reacción fue mover a los pacientes de
los hospitales a las tiendas porque las
instalaciones se dañaron y luego
empezamos a trabajar en el área
colindante y poco a poco estamos
trabajando en el sur
hemos llevado a cabo algunas cirugías
pero principalmente estamos
estabilizando a los pacientes además en
puerto príncipe- tenemos otras
actividades que ya existían y están
admitiendo a pacientes pero tan solo en
las primeras 20 a 24 horas recibimos más
de 30 pacientes de la ciudad de lekai
también le preguntamos a nuestra
invitada sobre la polémica que hubo en
su momento y también que se mantiene
incluso hasta en la actualidad por la
distribución de los fondos de ayuda tras
el terremoto de 2010 que no
necesariamente se dedicaron a la
reconstrucción y fueron utilizados en
actos de corrupción
es un reto que el gobierno tiene que
afrontar no puedo responder por ellos
nosotros usamos fondos privados
somos directamente responsables de los
fondos que usamos para emergencia
pero el gobierno está haciendo lo mejor
que puede para coordinar diferentes
niveles de intervención
pero dependerá de ellos que el dinero
llegue a donde debe ser
masnoticias en venezuela el presidente
de la asamblea nacional jorge rodríguez
valoró de manera positiva que la
oposición reconociera al gobierno ya las
instituciones presididas por nicolás
maduro al firmar el memorándum de
entendimiento en la mesa de diálogo en
mexico
asimismo rodríguez pidió a la comunidad
internacional que dejen de amenazar y
presionar a venezuela para el buen
avance de los diálogos las partes en
reunidas en la ciudad de mexico intentan
buscar en un punto común para la
solución a la crisis política económica
y social que está afectando a ese país
suramericano
en eeuu se declararon allí la escasez de
agua para el lago mead el mayor
reservorio de este país a partir del
primero de enero del 2022 el gobierno
federal restringirá el uso del agua para
ciertos fines especialmente para la
agricultura según los expertos esta
situación se debe en gran parte al
calentamiento global que provoca sequías
más intensas y más largas en esta región
del planeta el informes de amal benotman
es un símbolo de los graves problemas de
sequía en el oeste de eeuu por primera
vez la agencia encargada de los recursos
del agua declaró una escasez en el lago
med el mayor reservorio hídrico del país
persona nunca hubo una declaración de
escasez así que el hecho de que estemos
asistiendo a la primera declaración es
bastante significativo históricamente la
escasez provocará cortes del suministro
de agua y restringir a su uso para la
agricultura a partir de octubre los
agricultores ya se están preparando
estaremos perdiendo alrededor de la
mitad de nuestra agua para usar el
próximo año así que vamos a tener que
recortar hectáreas de la producción que
tenemos ahora los niveles de agua del
reservorio han estado bajando durante
años una de las consecuencias del ciclo
de sequía que afecta a la región byrs y
estamos viendo los efectos del cambio
climático a través de la cuenca del río
colorado a través de sequías prolongadas
y temperaturas extremas incendios
forestales expansivos y en algunos
lugares inundaciones y deslizamientos de
tierra en la es uno de los reservorios
artificiales que almacenan el agua de
río colorado este embalse abastece a
siete estados estadounidenses y partes
de méxico
según un estudio de la agencia geológica
de eeuu el flujo de río colorado ha
disminuido en un promedio del 20 por
ciento durante el siglo pasado una
disminución que no sólo afecta al lago
med sino a todas las fuentes de agua del
oeste de eeuu incluido el lago power la
segunda reserva del país y miles de
personas han tenido que huir de sus
viviendas campamentos y hoteles en la
riviera francesa ante el avance de
avance de varios focos de incendios que
han arrasado más de cinco mil hectáreas
de bosques la mayor conflagración
comenzó el lunes en la tarde a unos 40
kilómetros de la ciudad de santiago para
un popular destino de vacaciones que
pasa justamente en este momento por el
pico de la temporada de verano el
poderoso viento del mediterráneo también
la ausencia de lluvias y la baja humedad
han permitido la fácil propagación de
las llamas
italia grecia turquía israel también
siguen luchando contra los focos de
incendios forestales
y el ministerio de ambiente de paraguay
bloqueó las operaciones de una
curtiduría local en la ciudad de
paraguarí al encontrar que varios de los
desechos de esta planta cayeron en un
estanque a cielo abierto y cuyas aguas
se tiñeron de color rojo está la
situación
las aguas del lago ypoá en paraguay hoy
están rosadas el responsable durling una
fábrica de curtiembre local contra la
cual un habitante de la zona presentó
una denuncia formal y vo tener una
industria ahí o sea evidentemente todo
lo que ahí se pueda procesar va a
filtrar
y eso va directo al equipo no es que va
a quedarse por el camino los habitantes
salieron a las calles temiendo a las
consecuencias que esto puede tener en su
comunidad y el ecosistema la situación
alarma las autoridades locales es
realmente desesperante y le termina el
oxígeno de los ojos los peces se ahogan
o de lo contrario por las toxinas que
ingieren porque se abrían los peces
estaban todos negros por dentro es decir
no no es más carnal lo que estamos
viviendo verdad el ministerio del
ambiente y desarrollo sostenible de
paraguay bloqueó las operaciones de la
fábrica durieux y estableció medidas
correctivas que la empresa deberá
cumplir de manera inmediata por ahora
sin efecto alguno sobre el color del
agua
la empresa deberá eliminar en su
totalidad del efluente líquido que se
haya contenido en la superficie
aproximada de dos hectáreas y una vez
eliminado dicho líquido remover
totalmente los taludes y diques
construido para restituir las
condiciones naturales del área este no
es el primer caso de aguas contaminadas
en paraguay pero sin duda alguna uno de
los más impactantes con esto llegamos al
final de las noticias de france 24 pero
les recuerdo que pueden ver estas y
otras noticias también en france 24
punto com en las redes sociales y en la
app sigan con nuestra programación muy
buenas noches para todos
[Música]